a democrat says president biden is lying
about the border crisis
congressman henry cuellar accusing the
white house of sharing misleading photos
of a cleared out migrant facility in
texas
cuellar is one of the people who exposed
the same jam-packed place that biden
wouldn't let the media see
according to the congressman migrants
are simply being moved to a different
location
quote all they're doing is they're
moving kids from one tent to the other
ten and saying
oh they're not in the border patrol
custody
but they're right next door they're just
next door in hhs
the news has texas officials fuming
the biden administration is totally
concealing all
information coming out from the border i
walked in one
room and it was empty but the next room
had 1200 kids in it you know you can
take a photo of an empty room and say no
one's here
or take the photo of what's really
happening
jesse maria bartoromo last week was the
first to report this she did a flyover
with governor abbott of texas and showed
the expanded donna facility with all
these new tents where the children had
been moved
yeah i told my twins to clean their room
the other weekend
and i said are you guys finished and
they said yeah dad come in
i walked into the room it looked clean
and then i opened the closet
and they'd stuffed all their dirty
clothes and toys into the closet
that's joe biden could you imagine if
donald trump said a fake news media come
take a look
no kids no crisis right and then next
story stuffed a thousand miners into a
room
this is crazy the joe biden is literally
helping the cartels smuggle kids
playing hide and seek with the media and
then picks a dandelion for jill and the
media says oh my gosh what a romantic
do you remember about what was it three
years ago everybody talked about
the flores settlement u.s law prohibits
the government from holding minors
longer than 72 hours
the the the hour donald trump held a
child past 72
the media called him a nazi joe biden
has held 25
000 children for about a month and no
one says a thing
is anybody paying attention here he has
turned the border patrol into a bunch of
babysitters
and while they're babysitting these
miners the cartels are just smuggling
adults and narcotics across the other
side
he could end this crisis tomorrow just
bring back the remaining mexico policy
it's that simple
have everybody wait in mexico to get
their asylum cases resolved
that's what trump did but joe's too
ashamed to go back to the trump policy
because he's afraid of his base and he
wants to save face
juan it does smack off nothing to see
here despite the fact that a record
number of migrant children are in
custody
let's see how those children are being
cared for in the hhs facilities
right i mean look if they're playing
shell games i say hold the politicians
accountable it's that's not
good politics and it's not good or
humane treatment
as biden's been bragging about you know
we want to treat these children in
keeping with american values
and you know sort of humanely um but i
will say this i was reading in the wall
street journal this morning
it said uh that conditions are improving
uh what it said was that there's a sharp
decline in children
in border patrol custody as uh jesse was
just saying and we're seeing children
more quickly processed uh out of even
the hhs
facilities and into the real homes of
sponsors people who are willing to take
them in
uh and deal with them until these
speeding claims can be reviewed
no it's not jesse i think it's speeding
up
so that those children are not held in
any government facility
this week by the way we've even seen
some reunions of children who were
separated from parents during the trump
administration
very few but again to me it's a
difficult situation i'll even say you
know you guys like to use the word
crisis a crisis situation
and we're seeing steady improvement i
would just say
you know i still am very frustrated i
mean everyone can point fingers
but where is congress where is marco
rubio you know
lindsey graham these guys signed and
wrote a
immigration bill in 2013. now they won't
even talk about it it's that politically
un
you know unmarketable but they're
willing to go down there and take
selfies please well
dana the immigration reform is not going
anywhere when you have this many
children
in migrant facilities that the american
people can't even see
and that wall street journal article
that juan pointed out said
hhs did not respond to detailed
questions
about conditions inside the emergency
facilities
and that there was there was such
insufficient staff at a facility in
houston that children couldn't even be
taken to the bathroom
and they were forced to relieve
themselves in water bottles
yeah that is not a that is tragic and
i think a couple of things um
legislation won't go anywhere until
there's a border security that's just
the way that it is
um it would be different i think if ted
cruz had released this picture right and
look at this this is a terrible thing
but no it was henry cuellar he is a
democrat in texas
she's trying to raise the alarm but not
only henry cuellar
people think a lot about kristin cinema
she's in arizona just a little bit more
well-known than mark kelly
he's a freshman senator there in arizona
he has a very tough race coming up
because he
was in a run he was in a appointed seat
and they had to run again in 2022.
and now the national republican
senatorial committee they've already
zeroed in on him
well what happened yesterday both cinema
and mark kelly are saying we need more
from the biden administration they have
to do more so border politics
not necessarily breaking along political
lines but
along ideol ideological lines if i could
just also say one i
um those stories that the
somehow the administration they don't
have a lot of fingerprints on it but
they're
organizing very touching videos of
families being reunited
after being separated in the trump
administration
but there's very little in these stories
that say okay well
do they get to stay and also what about
all the families that are being
separated right now for example
they know that children won't be sent
back so what are they doing they're
giving their kids to
coyotes and letting them drop them over
the border so it's just a lot more
complicated
than like that stor those stories i tip
my hat from a pr standpoint but it just
really
really is not the full story greg yeah
um i you know juan was correct this is
this is a shell game
and it's actually really cartoonish in
its brazenness
i mean it's like they why did they think
that they could get away with it and
such they were like
hey let's move on let's do an actual
shell game let's move
all these kids over here and pull one
over on the median
because they thought they could pull one
over on the media
if that democrat hadn't called this out
i wonder if anybody would have known
maybe sooner or later we'd figure it out
but the picture
itself was just easily absorbed by a
media that was like hey that's good
enough for us that's the evidence we
need
but this hide-and-seek uh maneuver it's
not just on the border
you know you're seeing this a lot with
um criminals and and mentally ill that
have been released
you know during the pandemic and they
end up on the street they end up uh
hurting people we've seen this a lot in
new york city
and what happens the democratic
leadership just they just put these
people in hotels
they hide them oh we solved the problem
and they just shove them off somewhere
and then some you know poor little asian
ladies walk up the street gets hit by a
hammer
or gets punched by somebody and it's
like wow where did that oh it's because
they thought that there were no homeless
there but they're just living in these
hotels
all over new york city we've got to stop
this hide and seek and actually solve
the problem
my problem is that biden and co just
think the american people are stupid
that they can show you some pretty
pictures in an empty facility and
we'll just move on and stop asking
questions meantime they're the ones
swimming in idiocy
and callousness hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else